[Music]
in McQuillen news submitted by violin
solo [ __ ] amazing on this date do it
again right a 20 year old man has been
arrested for being accused of killing
four people in Tampa through your nose
so Tampa was on edge for a couple months
because there were this killing spree
happening four people died really close
together on the map so this is what the
map what makes it killing spree a
killing spree like when you kill
multiple people when you try to play GTA
in real life maybe it's a certain time
span certain area a certain style and
then like movies a style killer was the
weapon it's like a shopping spree leave
like a little clue like the ballistics a
pixie sticks
oh I'm the pixie killer this is where
the victims were killed that's so sad
what happened oh they all look so
different they're not yeah they're not
really it's the killer was going
multicultural with it like they were it
was a equal opportunity killer what
should they call him ick killers maybe
they're all girly that McDonald's mm-hmm
that was the link well as of now they
don't know what the correlation was
between the victims and there's no
motive either they haven't gotten a
motive from this guy so the killer is
this 24 year old name how old's
Donaldson the third this is what he
looked all such an eloquent man this is
the killer
sounds like a knife he looks like an NFL
football player how a lot us in the
third yeah and so those four murders so
the first one happened on October 9th it
was Benjamin Mitchell got killed 22
years old he was at a bus
all these people they were everybody got
British names in this area
I know Benjamin and Michelle you just
said in a British accent
Benjamin Mitchell Quan zhang ziyi yes
and then the second victim was Monica
Hoffa
32 years old killed on October or her
body was found on October 10 miles from
where Mitchell was killed and then on
October 19th Anthony Nyota 20 he was on
that British looking he was killed after
taking the wrong bus home from work and
authorities said that he had like a mild
form of autism 200 the last victim was
Robert Felton 60 years old he was shot
from the back Oh
November 14th and how do they know it's
all of these guys were done by
ballistics the ballistics yeah they were
all shot yeah they all were shot by the
same exact time so the way that they
found out it was helices for the cops
they had about over 5,000 tips about all
these murders and everyone was just
scared his big yeah you don't know who's
gonna die there's no there's no like
sequential exactly yeah and you don't
know what's gonna happen next it'd be a
fifth guy a six person seven person
exactly it was just a rage thing we
don't have a motive but we don't know so
then the way they found it was because
how will he works at McDonald's and so
he gave a food bag with his 40 caliber
Glock and bullets in the McDonald's food
bag to his manager and so her name is
delando Walker it's like a Happy Meal
toy yeah
and so he gave it to the manager he's
thinking like he just told her like
don't look inside of it just keep it for
safekeeping for now I'll call you and
I'll tell you what to do with it and
then he had also mentioned to a
co-worker it I he was I'm gonna [ __ ]
it's a heavy [ __ ] thing it is like
what the [ __ ] is it here yeah what job
can you tell the manager what to be on
opening that up
I guess he trusted her to not look into
the back what she did because they're
reporting like he didn't give it to her
on purpose to get caught like he really
thought that she would not look in
the back so then obviously she did she
called the police and cuz he had taken
off and then when he went back to the
McDonald's that's when police met him
and that was just the final thing they
needed which was a gun because the gun
was the link with all the kills why did
he just like bury it somewhere and then
cuz he trusted her she's a [ __ ] snitch
he also mentioned to a co-worker like he
was planning on leaving the state so
that's why it's gonna go back to England
I think he's from England
yeah yeah all of them oh I feel like he
had like the Glock and he just like
passed her the bag and as he just tore
don't look what fell out do not look at
what just fell out
okay drop them a boom this is so not a
yard because they weird he always had he
obviously had somewhat of a plan but
then all of his murders were random yeah
and like so he bought that gun legally
and just a few days later that's when he
had just started his killing spree
well Florida has a different law from us
I don't know if they have the 10-day
wait you guys watch mine hunters on it I
keep past always that the meat yeah yeah
so basically it's about like in the when
the FBI started profiling serial killers
I saw the first episode because it
wasn't a thing back in the day they used
to just think that murders were all lust
killings and when they were able to
actually study these people that they
were as if there was a pattern either a
pattern of abuse or a pattern of how
they chose their victims but this kind
of just sounds like he just it was very
random or he's being framed
maybe well he confessed or he loved
drama yeah he confessed to the fact that
that is his gun he owns that gun no one
else has touched that gun since it's
been in his possession but he hasn't
confessed to the killings what so we
don't know what's happening there the
guns mine the pellets of mine the bullet
in the head of the people are mine also
from nine days mine everything but I did
not pull the trigger they haven't said
that he's denied it either is just that
he hasn't a lot of them are narcissist
they want people to know yeah and as a
matter of fact
they actually they they work with police
very closely giving them informational
how's the case going they're very a lot
of them are very eager to know if
they're being talked about because
they're narcissists mmm that's using it
I think that this guy gave the bag or
the gun in the bag on purpose hoping
that it would leave some kind of shrimp
well it's easy to catch him then you
just put him into a room right you have
some other guy there he goes
I'm the one who did the case club I just
pictured that guy he's getting
irritating it's like the other person
was lying those yeah when I kill the
mouse for he's just like mother happened
you're right because historically there
have been serial killers who because
they the cops lost the trail on them
they eventually turned themselves in oh
they could have gotten away yeah exactly
you stop trying that's all you got to
play a little hard to get so I we don't
care about you anymore what I killed
it's like baby they like to be pursued
what happened I thought you really into
me before this dude about cut police had
released surveillance footage of a
person of interest so they caught like a
figure in one of the CCTV footage is
that they had and his McDonald's
co-workers joked around with this dude
saying like oh that could be you you
look like you're the killer and they're
saying like when they said that like
you'd get angry at his care no let me
these are racist what it is it is I want
to know why yeah that's what we all want
to know no one knows why what are you
four years old yes so young why why I
walk and now they're looking to see all
right now the trials gonna begin he's
being held without bond until the trial
but they're just saying like the Mayor
was like he deserves to die he's a
shitty criminal though I don't know any
killer that's gonna shoot people with a
store-bought gun the illegally obtained
gun like even I have all my guns
illegally obtained but if I were to kill
someone
not out of self-defense I probably go by
an illegal gun so that they can't really
trace it back to me so he didn't think
things through actually yeah he's gonna
feel better dude yeah everyone that
knows him say that he was a quiet polite
young man even his but everyone always
says stuff like that no one ever goes
yeah that [ __ ] I knew it was
just a matter of time where there's
signs where you can clearly see like
this dude's messed up yeah some reason
every time I read i watch the news or
something to like you know what my
neighbor was so nice I would have never
known they had 50 slaves there's this
dude near my parents store like he
basically like broke into my car and he
jacked my my sony vaio laptop but I just
got it knew the kid I knew I know he did
it a couple of months or whatever I
can't run the time Sam but either way he
got shot he got killed right but on the
news he was like he was such a good kid
he was a church boy oh my god the
sweetest kid I was like that was a
gangbanger what are you talking about no
no but people never say that I did they
find their like graduation for that
thing they're all like that dude in a
tuxedo yeah so it was the fact that they
found the gun and also they found cell
phone location data that pinned him
mirrors yeah he really sucks activity
and then also the bullet casings match
Wow still not he wanted to get caught
but he's like innocent until proven
guilty so we don't know yeah well I mean
the cops are saying that he was being
very cooperative and the he consented to
them searching his car searching like
his cell phone records searching
everything don't be mean he was really
nice he was actually really nice about
everything really really nice guys just
it's cool yeah and so now the manager
who called in the tip will receive the
110 thousand dollar reward like yeah
that's why she snitched she said that
the reward never entered her mind
the right thing soon even did you give
it back she was she like you know what I
don't want it I wanna like I did it
across my mind this is about I don't
want it I should do that I don't think
she did Judas Bart gave you a bag where
they're gone and say don't look at it
just trust me
oh we're arguing I'm like why can't I
look at it yeah like I want to look at
she's just nosy too though
I'm very but then would you be an
accomplice and just never rat or never
support no I wouldn't step that's it
comes you will never snack like this wow
what is this thing I'm not curious that
you play we're having that whatever like
nothing there's literally nothing [ __ ]
you if I whatever you say you do that
what it sounds like [ __ ] you every time
yeah would you do that though if Bobby
came up gave you a bag yeah clearly
there's a gun in it and he's like hey I
need you to hide this don't say [ __ ]
and yes sweat dripping down his forehead
like he'd been running she over this in
a hash it's a hash let me killed like my
sister or someone very dear to my heart
we're strangers it doesn't matter no I'm
with him right or die unfortunately yeah
you know what that's good criminal
that's admirable but also you're a piece
of [ __ ]
[Music]